-♪ "Musical Genre Challenge" ♪
-How it works is
we're going to take turns
hitting this button right here.
-Right, okay.
-This activates
the Random Genre Generator.
-Mm, the Random G-G--
-Genre Generator.
-Genre Gen-- Okay.
Genre Generator.
-[ French accent ] You land on
one random song title
and one random musical genre.
-Oui, oui.
Voilà.
-Uh, baguette.
-Croissant.
-Stripe shirts.
Beret.
-David Bacon.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ]
Whoever's turn it is
has to sing that song
in that style.
Jamie, if you don't mind,
I will start us off.
-You know what? Go ahead.
It's your show.
-Here we go.
Ready?
-Oh, you got a mic.
-All right, the song
I'm gonna get is...
"Can't Feel My Face."
The genre --
Roots, '50s crooner.
Like a '50s song.
The brushes are out.
-And the brushes are out.
[ Smooth jazz plays ]
-♪ I can't feel my face
when I'm with you ♪
♪ Oh, but I love it ♪
♪ I can't feel my face
when I'm with you ♪
♪ Oh, but I love it ♪
♪ I love not feeling my face ♪
♪ Can't feel it, oh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Roots are just that good.
That was good.
All right. '50s crooner.
-Oh, snap.
I can't feel --
-I like not feeling my face.
Jamie. Jamie.
-All right,
here we go, here we go.
All right.
Shhh-- Shazam.
[ Laughter ]
-"Who Let the Dogs Out?"
-What?
-As done like
a Broadway musical.
So "Who Let the Dogs Out?"
by -- by Baha Men.
-Okay.
-Done as a Broadway musical.
Roots, I don't know
how you're gonna do this.
Jamie, I don't know how
you're gonna do this.
[ Soft ballad plays ]
-You know, just the other day,
I was walking, and I saw dogs.
And I was wondering to myself,
"Where -- Where did they
come from?"
Somebody must have let them out.
There was a cocker spaniel.
And then I saw a pit bull,
and, you know,
they can be cantankerous.
Those pit bulls
can be cantankerous.
I wouldn't want anybody
to get hurt,
so I just said to myself...
♪ Who let the dogs out? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who?
♪ Who let the dogs out? ♪
♪ Who, who, who, who-who ♪
♪ Who, who let the dogs out? ♪
♪ Who, who ♪
And I said...
♪ Who let the, who let those
doggone dogs out? ♪
♪ I said, who let the ♪
Especially the pit bull!
♪ Who let those dogs
ou-u-u-u-u-t? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music stops ]
♪ Then I realized ♪
[ Somber music plays ]
♪ I knew
who let those dogs out ♪
♪ Just above the ridge ♪
♪ I could see a vision ♪
♪ And that vision ♪
♪ That vision ♪
♪ Was me-e-e-e-e-e ♪
I let the dogs out.
It was I.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh. Ohh.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughs ]
You let the dogs out!
-It was me!
I let the damn dogs out.
-That was --
"It was I." That was beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
-It was I.
Was it you?
It was I.
-Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, man.
Oh, yeah, man.
-"Bad and Boujee."
-Oh, yeah.
This is crazy.
[ Rock music plays ]
[ Imitating Mick Jagger ]
♪ Rain drops, drop tops ♪
♪ Smokin' on cookie
in the hotbox ♪
♪ Rain drops, drop tops ♪
♪ Smokin' on cookie
in the hotbox ♪
♪ I'm bad and boujee ♪
♪ Cookin' up dope with a Uzi ♪
♪ We got 30s
and 100 rounds, too ♪
♪ You know that I'm bad
and I'm boujee ♪
♪ Bad and boujee ♪
♪ Bad and I'm boujee ♪
-♪ Bad and I'm boujee ♪
-♪ Bad ♪
-♪ I'm bad and I'm boujee ♪
-♪ I'm bad, I'm boujee ♪
♪ I'm bad, I'm boujee ♪
-♪ I'm bad ♪
-♪ Bad bad bad ♪
And boujee.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right,
all right, all right.
-Yo, why -- Hey, yo,
why y'all messing around?
-Yeah.
-That thing hot.
[ Laughter ]
-That was a good one?
-You gotta put that thing
on the Soundcloud or --
[ Laughter ]
-All right, here we go.
-Or "Beat Shazam."
Last one. You're up.
You're up on this one.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
Jamie, you're up.
-Oh -- Oh, yeah.
[ Clears throat ]
Come back.
Come back, Foxx.
-Here we go.
-Shazam.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
"Bitch Better Have My Money,"
Rihanna, but do it as an opera.
-Oh, what?
[ Dramatic opera music plays ]
♪ Bitch ♪
♪ Better have
my mone-e-e-e-e-y ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ You should know me
well enough ♪
♪ Bitch better have my money ♪
♪ Please don't call me
on my bluff ♪
♪ Pay me ♪
♪ What you owe me ♪
♪ Like brrap, ba,
brrap, brrap ♪
♪ Wah, wah, wah, wah,
wah, wah, wah, wah, wah ♪
♪ Wah, wah, wah, wa-a-a-a-a-h ♪
♪ Bitch better ha-a-a-a-a-ve ♪
♪ My mone-e-e-e-e-e-y ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bitch!
-[ Laughs ]
Jamie Foxx!
The most talented man on Earth,
Jamie Foxx.